how you doing
oh my god i'm totally freaking out it's
so nice to see
you you know when the last time we met
was i remember it well
it was on a set and
saying yeah and i had a huge crush on
you
but weirdly i decided to tell you that i
had a huge crush on corey feldman
i mean you must have had girls like
falling at your feet what was it like to
be
that guy but i don't think i was i think
rob lowe was that guy
i was the other guy um you know i was
very
shy person then suddenly i was very in
the public and present and people are
coming up to me and stuff i found that
all kind of
weird and bizarre i've heard that you
felt like a little bit of an outsider
sometimes
with the brat pack like what is your
relationship now
where what's going on with the other
members
well we the last meeting was cancelled
because of covet but we're going to have
our
next brad pack reunion next month i'm so
excited are you kidding me
i am kidding you no but i was just doing
rob lowe's podcast last week and
rob was like we got to get everybody
together one room
big dinner lock the doors and you know
we do because it was such an
odd singular time and it happened to
a small group of people and it so
affected our lives
so thoroughly and you know you know
you've lived your life
in public your whole life you're more
public than me in that way but it
it totally alters who you become as a
human yes
absolutely very blessed thing i mean who
are we kidding
it is a blessed thing and i think you
make a very conscious
decision somewhere along the way of
you know how you're gonna handle and
receive that kind of energy
and how you're going to treat people and
and how you exchange energy
uh is a very big question one must have
to come up with an answer for
you know i just get i i got i realized a
long time ago i just got too tired to
just try to be nice to everybody
you know did you were you able to
maintain that or were you more like
i'm human i'm honest you're catching me
oh
you know i i've had you know i have
three kids and my kids have melted down
in public and i have melted down in
public so badly with them
that at a certain point it's just like
oh my god this is so humiliating
no matter whether you're the public eye
or not you know so
you just sort of there we are warts and
all i'm so with you
i've had my daughter like on the
pavement like
pounding and screaming people walking by
i'm looking at you and you're just like
somebody said i heard um you know if
your children haven't embarrassed you
recently you're not paying enough
attention to your children
so i under i identify with that my of a
seven-year-old and he when he melts down
the world is ending you know at least i
know somewhere
this is gonna pass in the moment it
doesn't feel like it but you know
we have that perspective whereas young
people just they don't
haven't lived the time so they don't but
did you know that growing up because i
will say growing up in this business
you're expected to be an adult when
you're a kid
and my relationship with my mom was like
totally backwards she wasn't a parent
was was yours backwards and turned
upside down as well
well i started to become successful
right as my dad was sort of having a
a challenging time and so it changed the
dynamite becoming successful
changed the dynamic of every
relationship that i had how
uh how did you manage the relationship
with your dad i'm only curious because i
had to really navigate things with my
mom
um and it took many years to figure out
yeah
it took decades like a lifetime
you know i think i ran you know our
relationship dissolved for a number of
years
and then you know it sort of came a
little together
as we were older and i started to have
kids and then as my dad was dying we
sort of
i went to be with him and you know we
kind of put down the baggage of our past
and had
sort of a beautiful thing and you know
that was more for my own kids to be a
better parent you know what i mean
because i needed to reconcile with my
dad there'd been a lot of baggage that
we
had carried around whether it was real
or not for years and decades
and to be able to just go dump it and
say you know
i love you was a powerful thing i just
love that
but i have to say one thing my entire
life i've had
one wish when people said what would you
do if you didn't do what you did
occupationally speaking and my entire
life i've had the same answer and it was
to be a travel writer
and you became a travel writer
yeah it's the best thing yeah it's
absolutely great
um i stumbled into that travel traveling
changed my life and so i started writing
about it
and it sort of took on a life of its own
and became this
second career and it has been an amazing
journey for that
and you're right it does change you